what's up everybody I have the pleasure
to share with you some work from Oh
Queen Debbie here I'll just let him
introduce himself the reason why I want
to have him on the show this because he
designed a bunch of hand lettered stuff
for us like the master debater with a
cocky bastard so super cool that he's
agreed to come on the show and we're
going to attack blueberry cosmetic whoo
that's it what's really cool is to see
another artist at work and see how they
go through from one thing to the next
one
my name is Linda we're Laura Rowan's
Alice from the right Mexico Monterrey
Mexico and this is the logo I choose
this is a logo for agentic brand called
Oberg Matic they say to me that they
wanted to stay away from the classic
asean being trend did you say asian pink
yeah asian pink pink trang what is that
what is that tell us about the Asian
control I don't know what he told you I
were trying to avoid
I have a video here so I can show you
the process alright so go ahead and
place that video then I started to to
write the doctor work very cool to have
in mind the the dimensions are you
drawing this without any guides this is
just all freehand yeah just pretty honey
how did you know how to draw these kind
of letter forms and tell us a little bit
about your background
actually I don't graduate a few months
ago and I see that you're doing some
kind of serif typeface with some
flourishes like pulling up the top of
the B and marking it back in is that
deliberately trying to reference the
letter C in there somewhere
yeah something like that I was just
exploring and trying different things
and why did you decide to make the x
height of the be so high like it's got a
big lower belly that is just like Art
Nouveau style right
I'm just messing around with my pencil
and trying to see what I can make
why did you decide to draw out the lower
part of the belly of the be to kind of
go below the baseline so in a such an
exaggerated way was the thinking there
as I say like it I get lost in the
process of everything that's nothing so
somebody's watching this they're like
how do you decide which one to go with
do you find that having teachers or
classmates help you to kind of make the
right decision because sometimes when
you're making all the marks they're like
your children you love them all equally
and it's sometimes very hard to decide
okay because it is vscocam okay miss
referencia Sammy Sado is my opponent
that he had to find all the good samples
of work in references and artists to
mold himself after just on the Internet
so why go to school then yes he got even
if in like whele
yeah you're right I don't know I didn't
learn anything let's keep going let's
keep talking
that's what my final auction
the final monogram mm-hmm it looks
really good it's very handsome there may
be some issues with the shadow line of
course what's the shadow line on that
it's that little shadow line that we're
seeing oh you see so you couldn't
probably see it right graduate designers
can do this for two reasons one to
separate the letters from kind of all
bleeding together but it creates a
trompe l'oeil if you will about what's
in front what's behind and we know that
these are two-dimensional images this is
just pixels on a screen right now but it
makes it feel like it's going back in z
space and then tell us about the
typeface that you're using here to pair
with I chose the Optima Nova for the
blueberry you can even think it has some
serif but it's just like the weight
playing with the main structure okay and
for the cosmetic I use it Germany's a
very humid rig
pond and what I like optimize the go to
cosmetic typeface you guys because it
straddles the line between a sans-serif
typeface and a serif typeface it has
flared strokes good job there dude I
want to show you also a little process
of day when I vectorize day oh yeah I
would love to see you vector eyes and
control that 80% of the Louis my
templates gabe's is the special software
is this freeware shareware how much is
the cost for glyphs it has a free
version and a premium version how much
is the premium version do you know I
don't know I have the free one yeah I
like this so far more than in the Phaedo
for digitizing my layers because it gave
me more control for the curves and I can
be more precise about measures with and
there's a couple of colored options some
some color options color options color
options okay beautiful sorry guys I'm
trying to be funny today I told you you
have to begin me the show right Erin
yeah oh ooh hold on a second here Oh Oh
what's going on you're doing a bunch of
mock-ups you know what I'm thinking Erin
what's up these guys are taking it to
the next level
tell me where you got these mock-ups and
what are you doing with this just talk
me through it
well Nesta meant a locum pray a year's
gratis maybe with da entonces if they lo
that car gay he didn't like any of the
free ones so yesterday he shelled out
some cash oh no are you kidding me he
did he you went out and bought the
products he bought the mom
oh my pay attention here just what the
kind of dedications gonna take this guy
div' air just went out and just did his
own he went out and bought products he
lit it he photographed it and he did his
own mock-ups one-of-a-kind good job man
I'm just gonna give you a copy right now
to do a good job very good maybe I
should have chimed in sooner but I think
there might be a misunderstanding here
oh this is a mock-up that he bought yeah
he didn't buy each little thingy and lay
it out and take a picture
he this is it this is a mock-up no no
come on you little controversy did you
screw up the translation or as I'm high
okay yep that's pretty much it the
process you're gonna see here okay guys
this is your opportunity in the show to
go ahead and comment on this and let us
know what you think
despite the controversy this is gonna be
like a Barry Bonds moment there's a
little a stress on this episode whether
or not I was high or not well we'll
never know I guess
well we will know because I can watch
the tape again and then we'll know isn't
it how that works yeah I just live in
the future thanks for watching thanks
for tuning in and if you liked this and
you want to see more episodes like this
of course stay tuned and say subscribe
to this channel but if you want to take
a deeper dive into a structured course
consider taking the logo design
construction class that's available
right like here somewhere
thanks for watching everybody I hope you
liked this episode if you do you know
what to do hit that like button if you
don't let us know in the comments below
and don't forget to subscribe see you
guys next time